I've been making videos for 10 years
they were just within like closed
Facebook groups so like people even hear
the general stuff but like for five
years before that I had a chain of gyms
and so I was making content I was
teaching classes live every single day
talking giving instruction talking to
people every single day I had sales
consults every single day and so you
have to learn how to communicate with
people and I think that that was just a
rocky cut scene that only people have
seen the end of that journey and being
like man you're so good at this but it's
just been thousands of hours of
repetition even in the gym launch days I
had a call that I set every single day
it was open mic 90 minutes every day
that any gym owners that wanted to hop
on and ask questions that were tactical
I would be there just answer so I got
really good at fast q a because I did it
all day every day for years